I'm gonna call me for the Dan Bilzerian
podcast the guy suited with my [__]
most of my busted life's but defending
that [__] short I don't know why he
defend it it was a hunkajunk it was a
[__] was this you weekly take to be fair
though at least it was original their
original [__] that's what we do on this
show
do you like news but with a little bit
of sex always mixed in words humor it's
actually sort of driven humor yeah
that's where we differ the keemstar in
no point when I'm watching kun do my
thing time for a wank yeah yeah you know
me there is with us every 10 sec I know
your thing at the moment right now and
it's not just cuz I'm mentioning it
that's putting it into your head it's
already there when you say us those two
guys what a sandwich all the meat all
the meat in your mouth this is time for
news
[Music]
challenger games was [__] wasn't a
combination cringe moments I think we
found our video ladies and gentlemen
fund you to tap lub preciate and the
thumbnail is a girl with a booty so you
know it's some sort of sexually charged
stuff right every 10 seconds I do
first-ever challenger games 2019 here in
Long Beach California fans you guys
ready to have a good time this is where
the Americans are so different than
English the bond it's just random a girl
doing a handshake and I guess this is
normal for the like high school type
thing that they've got over there
because they do a lot of athletics at
high school whereas we just do that a
rugby and cricket every now and then in
England it's a bit different how's that
hamstring no wait we're they competing
against each other I guess so I mean
it's personal glory at this point isn't
it okay Logan had Buster's hamstring
beforehand which is convenient nah but
to be fair how you see in the injury I
look like this I was like are you gonna
finally have this year this looks
[__] Terry but don't be afraid to
donate now it's basically the shrunken
sponsor and then given like a you know
he's got a very amazing voice but known
me afraid yeah I know I have an annoying
voice yes I worry that when we're on
screen people think that's me everyone's
excited I'm like oh they gave me the the
the actual gig is fine it's weird
because he still claims he wants a
boxing match she wants to get back into
boxing yeah he's doing this he's 50 and
nobody in the YouTube community knows
who the [__] he is he was a world
heavyweight champion boxer a long time
ago make no mistake about I wouldn't
want to take a punch off this dude but I
think he's 50 yeah I think I can run
away from him like I can run away from
you you're probably not in shape the
played the other side of it is you know
when you you know in a like a small
object breaks and you can hear something
rattling around inside it and you just
give it a still going
I think he's hoping that someone will
punch him so the thing inside him stops
rattling yeah and he can just stop let's
go chip that's horribly accurate
is a good first this is a good good
tasting let's say you know because it's
just voice right your ass and yet who's
really comforting thing when you live
stream every week like we do you know
not to do that but maitre said I'm a fan
of this mic I think he carries that
impulsive it's hard to do this just on a
you turn up on the day you get judged
for everything you do every mistake is
there it's hard
III think we're the only two people who
probably advertise that these guys cost
Jake is actually fast the fact that Jake
Paul beat Tobit Toby's like when he
didn't beat him away came very
marginally snow no Jake one that I could
see who is this kid this is I've got a
question this kid followers Jake Paul
everywhere who the [__] is this is mini
Jake polo ever they call him who the
[__] is he who does he actually belong
to did they just buy it who the [__] is
his real parent so why do they rent him
of the Jake [__] I don't get it I
don't know what's going on oh my god
this cameraman is a perfect at the same
time if they're gonna turn up wearing
skin tight pale leggings with their
every sort of inch on shore these women
are athletes so we're getting we're
getting set up for the women's 100 meter
hurdles right now that was an awkward
hug she sees them coming
you watch them there and then up and I'm
gonna go back to the phone and ignore oh
I've got no choice and then it could see
what happened between those two there's
something got on there what the [__] is
froth and doing geo just used the shot
that whatever's Romans getting right now
is hanging there like it wasn't what we
had in mind yeah there was one girl
hurdles she just smoke everyone I see
him it could be this this girl here
watch I look at her look at this girl go
Wow get up all those squats in the
[__] gym work I mean they don't just
build a booty they build off beasts
hurdles are harder than you think [__]
yeah yeah she's anticipating them yeah
she is so coordinated I'm really it
I mean imagine this commentary would
have been amazing yeah this is what you
could have had a little bit if you met
these kind of women Brian and you you
wanted to talk to them what sort of
stuff would you chat to them about I'll
just be like yeah that was that's pretty
easy
what are you doing after this yeah we
are we doing a party but are you making
eye contact to each going Oh what are
you
doing nah I'm doing say I feel really
fat after losing that event vacation yes
I am I really am a loser and I look at
me
I mean look with all those guys over
there with their six-packs in that I
just I just feel deflated then you got
yeah and then that's when they feel
sorry for you but what are you gonna do
do you know I mean have you got any
spare medals cuz I could I just wanted
one really you got a goal whatever I'm
gone you could it out guys sure and if
it is being a loser then I'm gonna be
the best loser you've ever seen okay so
ultimately you're a winner right these
are some of the signs to look out for
for dangerous people in a club girls so
anyone who says that sort of thing
definitely don't talk to me she is
literally just a porn star by the way
it's ironic she is the in my opinion the
best athlete at this as some of the
things she's done all right
pretty good right she's done the
specialist Olympic a long jump right
yeah the long pump all cash back I must
submit even for me this camera guy is an
actual perv I'm all for having the odd
like glimpse and a bit of a job but he
is literally just doesn't give a [__]
does he even that other directors such a
pervert and the cameraman is like
reluctantly getting these shots but he's
got to do a good job Robin look down
Robin keep it on her cheeks yeah it's a
Toby chisel yeah on the right smokeless
this was a fair one Toby winces yeah I'm
proud to Toby but yeah it's like a real
talk we should we slug everyone off like
he is one of the nicest [__] people
you could ever meet in this game it's
kind of boring do something nasty yeah
baby told ya for one thing seriously
coming this is a perfect this is a [__]
show yeah like the YouTube must turned
up in there did they a bit I mean the
production company you were dog [__] on
this one whoever you are massive event
big day for you oh [__] yeah Jake Paul
live stream does wedding-y ever you know
fake wedding right okay $49 he charged
for this [__] her stream 64,000 people
paid 50 quid no [__] way
do you really want to hurt me do you
really want to make me pay $50
may kiss the bride so weirdly just as
they're about to kiss someone interferes
and starts a fight Wow what real-life
drama ironically it reminds me of do you
remember when Triple H married Stephanie
McMahon that was actually like more
entertaining and a much more realistic
and they actually did get married
exactly so Fairplay at the table we for
once you guys did it the real way you
know I mean anyway you know although it
shoot Stephanie was unconscious the
first time but I was a great episode of
oh that was gross why is a random guy
pushing them just as they're about to
kiss though I'm all for setting up a
fake drama at a wedding or whatever it's
got to be logical yeah you know does
anyone have any reason why these two
should not be married I do yeah Jake
used to [__] maybe Hannah Montana the
other one skinny one the one he's really
yeah you know anyway generic blonde girl
she's in the crowd and she goes I do I
still love him yeah stop
yeah and in the name of love before you
break my heart oh dude
he actually said we're already thinking
of kids yeah
can we just know there's part of Jake
Paul that is a must umma is also part of
him that's like a Fame [__] he doesn't
give a [__] why people talk as long as
they're still talking because it's not
controversy creates crush like he he's
just relentless like you're quite
creative like you have got some talent
why not go the other room is it because
he's dress isn't like a character from
Jurassic Park he's dressed more like
Michael Jackson in smooth criminal' if
I'm honest with you sure that worries me
that's a children she is just as
calculated as him so she probably signed
up one yeah I mean I mean let's give
people something to [__] talk about
let's keep us relevant let's keep us in
the headlines we're gonna make a power
couple supergroup type [__] and if it
all goes to it we win anyway because
then people still care about I think you
are giving them too much credit what's
going on though and I think you're going
this masterminds has come up with all
these great things their latest
let's get married that they're currently
like sitting on a bed somewhere just
sort of eating popcorn right this is fun
isn't it like they're totally oblivious
to the level you two should have a baby
and sheers old jakey they'll be lovely
wouldn't he goes who will be [__]
lovely Snoop goons and they need to
start [__] and then their managers
just watching going excellent and now
coming to us live from a cupboard in
Kent
it's our news correspondent dead g8 edgy
hello sorry we should have addressed him
as sorry yeah that's that's bad is this
in his mother's bedroom that the
paintings on the back room I know this
is this is a classic decoration of a
dining room dining or a dining room but
yeah he's got us yeah you've got me
there
weird oh well this is where we come to
our unbiased correspondent that you not
the third you know what people say
they're not biased you start to think
they're biased hey Brian I'm not gay
me neither me no definitely no neither
of us again I never think about men's
asses yeah all their penises you would
tell me the other day how you never
think of a big veiny shaft yeah he
repeats himself like he moves the pencil
that background is awfully familiar look
I don't give a [__] if touchy rips
assault but genuinely like you don't own
the news brah
I definitely don't but it's just the way
the way the clips playing over a moving
background look exactly the same way we
I mean I didn't realize that do you even
watch this like I genuinely didn't yeah
until you saw the thumbnail the
execution the logo in the background I
just want you to know the impact that
you can have by making up stuff writing
email it basically cut a long story
short these to keep getting reported to
social services a surprise they're
basically made a business out of people
watching their kids yes it's legal I
don't agree with it morally I don't
necessarily agree with their life
choices they've made I don't think
bad people didn't he tweet you want yeah
I think he wanted to have a debate about
it but quite honestly you know some
debates are worth having some you just
know you're right so you decide right I
don't need this but I don't wish
anything bad on them no yeah not bad me
III say you know I I hope they have a
happy life all the [__] best I don't
necessarily agree with your choices but
you're they're clearly not I don't think
they're bad people
no I mean they just having lots of bad
news they've got weird stalker codes but
guess what when you put your little kids
out on the internet weird people are not
gonna watch you yes why for a few years
now I've been suggesting don't do it
maybe rely on your own talent sadly a
living off of people watching you and
not your kids
of course edgy in other news Tommy
Robinson's been locked up your feelings
on that is very edgy they're big Tommy
Robinson support a massive massive yeah
yeah who can blame em same sense and
style yeah dodgy you recently applied
for a job at the BBC presenting their
news obviously they famously employed
Jimmy Savile what did you think about
his death of The Times unfortunate piece
not sure I agree with you on that one
daddy but thanks for the honesty Trisha
Paytas has been giving everyone another
one of her great performance
[Music]
I can't believe people pay for this [__]
yeah I mean I can see why she's got
curves she's literally dressed like she
forgot to put the over garment on the
earth he's living a nightmare but going
what a dream I'm living a dream but
everyone else is being forced to be in
that nightmare yeah yeah she's like
who's the knife from the Friday the 13th
Freddy Krueger yeah she's mrs. Kruger so
you're just laying there asleep yeah I
will yeah I will make you [__] me and
then you're like no no and she's like
yeah but people she's probably got a fat
[__] you know many people like that
what are you saying you are holy [__]
she's big I didn't realize how big she
was I basically get paid using my
natural honestly realities no biggie
that's not an ability natural god-given
gifts orange maybe she calls this an
ability what should you have an ability
to be tall I do everything from height
size comparisons lifting carrying
smothering wrestling and just walking if
I'm out for a day in the park and I see
a man mounting a 6 foot 3 woman I reckon
rolls in the retort oh yeah Robin come
and have a look at this girl is this you
Robin wow you said this doesn't make me
feel sick instantly makes me think that
you felt sick how can that be normal to
do this in public how does this feel
good for him you're being carried like a
toddler there is absolutely no nudity no
sex no release nothing of the there's no
New Deal or nudity but she is in
lingerie and yes
wrestling with him and he's getting a
boner during it and also he's in that
big red head he's got there and it'll
earth brain purple-headed womb throat
this is it a festival recently not just
to give to me festival goers a little
bit of a warning we're trying to
encourage sexual health on the shore now
there's two big festival goers we love
Gaston if anything I can't think of
anything worse than basically cluster
right I don't want to do that [__]
in big bless I don't want to be
surrounded by people off their tits I'd
want to punch them baby okay that this
girl okay
uses the toilets as her own sort of flat
the way you know the way Brody uses the
park this girl is just being caught in
the toilets doing what what shagging
yeah so Jesus come out this girl here
the denim shorts on there she is with
loud number two same day obviously and
those toilets up I know that Horeb they
have furn up in one of easier then she's
taking large number three how is this
happening
yeah cuz these men don't know she's been
doing this all [__] day it was a big
place she's coming up to these random
guys go and fancier [__] and they're
like yeah sure why not I made a festival
probably high let's go for it
and what they don't know is her pussy's
being lined with other men's semen twice
over
that's like condom no does she [__] man
that's loud number three he is walking
off laughing apparently she had four
guys in the entirety of that just on
that one guy videoing her free love on
the free love freeway love is free in
their toilet stinks so this happened in
my hometown of Newcastle this girl is
really pissed off with this guy in this
Ford Focus and it all kicks off so this
has already been going on but by the
time he's gotten the camera out this guy
you've got to give up like she's got
some welly there she's putting some
Johnny on that oh my god and then this
this is the thing they could have ripped
her on clean out the socket then when
these guys drive off a random guy
walking up the pavement nearly gets
driven in yeah so then he's dragged into
this so he gets a knife to her hand
stuck in the door here I mean so that
this guy that they've just nearly driven
in on the pavement he's annoyed he's
running after that he would be he goes
to chase after them they reverse they're
like you're getting as well [__]
this is New Castle does it make you feel
when you watch that yeah yeah sounds
about right yeah seems like you ever
seen any [__] like this so you know I've
done it right Brian I'm about to show
you something that's gonna blow your
tiny little mind this is a dog doing
[__] special police training watch
this [__] no [__] this dog is [__]
blindfolded all right look at this [__]
the dog is blind dizzy but I unfolded or
is there holes in this where they've
gone let's make a look like he's playing
folder to make it look more impressive
sorry Brian are you saying that they
falsely blindfolded a dog which is then
doing this even this is impressive or
the dog has vision I feel like this dog
could rob a bank recreate Ocean's eleven
with women they recreate it with dogs
some people say they did in other news
ninja secured the bug twitch have lost
their biggest or most famous streamer in
my opinion in ninja he signed for the
streaming company miksa owned by
Microsoft for a [__] fortune yeah
basically it's blown the game wide open
in my opinion YouTube and twitch of HUD
basically had no reason to look after
their you know influencers or whatever
the [__] you want to call them no
because they are the only platforms you
want to upload videos youtube you wanna
stream twitch are have now purchased the
biggest name in the game for streaming
and all of a sudden it's like everyone
now cares about mixer I didn't know what
the [__] mix I was I've never even heard
of him one hundred thousand people in a
day before he's even done a streamer
mixer I've signed up the mixer he's put
them on the map
unlike literally it's no different you
like wrestling companies like if a
wrestling company starts up and they buy
all the best wrestlers everyone's gonna
watch them it same with the same with
football teams YouTube I want it to be
the same way because the power should
lie with the people who put bombs in
situ put I put the eyes on the screen
it's not about YouTube it's about the
people on YouTube yeah it's not about
twitch it's about the people on twitch
and it's about time that the big
companies realize that and if a company
started up tomorrow and when we're gonna
sign PewDiePie Logan Paul ksi all these
big names no one will give a [__] about
YouTube all of a sudden it's like I'm
watching this now I mean it's like all
of their fans move over all of the new
creators move over
you actually give them a better CPM you
actually give them better helps or when
they get copyright strike you actually
[__] help them and give a [__] like I
am welcoming this I want more companies
to do this you know what I'm saying yeah
and he's also going to mixer and then
got 80,000 views on his 8000 live views
on his first stream 80,000 concurrent
yeah that's amazing built the audience
we don't know how much he was paid for
this but I know he got paid a million
just to play Apex legends so you got
nothing to sign him for a number of
years for exclusivity we're talking a
[__] up people are saying between 10
and 100 million like a lot of huge
numbers are being imported twitch
removed his verification status and also
the I think one of the head honchos at
twitch courted his announcement with our
IP he's worried he's worried doesn't
make you look yeah it makes you look
bitter sour and like you just lost your
biggest guy you should have looked after
him this is a great move though and I
really hope that it brings other
companies to the table to try and sign
koreas and this becomes a normal thing
where we see great has given [__] tons
of money
now Brian in the past you've been a bit
disparaging of some of the gaming
community calling on [__] and
[__]
right just solely sometimes it's a bit
boring right what you haven't seen here
is this guy is now winning as much if
not more money than some of the top
athletes in the world
what's it though well he's won the world
cup of fortnight three million quid
three million pounds softly oh is it
sixteen now Brian is it better to
dedicate your time to a bloody
livestream as you call it or is it
better you pop on fortnight now start
getting good with these hooves I
genuinely played fortnight like a few
aims I was [__] [__] I gave up
straightaway yeah well apex II I'm not
that I'm a battlefield guy when it comes
to shooting now a lot of people were
questioning the validity of this as
prize money and saying it's not real
sport right I think the healthy thing to
do would be for the gaming community
maybe to acknowledge that and go but it
is something that attracts a lot of eyes
a lot of people see it Spencer saw the
word have you
we should on his Twitter and find out
but every day I think it should be
looked at as a waste of time as long as
you're using it properly and you're
focusing your attention in the right way
but these guys as much as it a lot of
people don't like say it these guys are
athletes I'm gonna have to stop your
race before people get you know only
going in on Spencer no Spencer's wanna
be best mates in this football industry
but got a disagree on that Ashley is a
stretch you know what I'm saying
the requires dedication and dedicating
it requires time and energy in the same
way athletes need to dedicate themselves
to this ball it's a lot more like darts
players and snooker players you know
athlete they're not you know it's a
golfing it got golfing I think golfing
requires more athleticism even you know
it because you have to have a bit of
strength behind you you do like nobody
whereas darts and pool you just need a
wander around a table the table let's
keep it real you need hand-eye
coordination right that is it that is
what we're talking about that's amazing
but not and there's a tiny minut level
of athleticism to do that much in the
way you gotta walk the cut your bust
some names you know what I'm saying
yeah but you got as a whole day yeah
there's athleticism when you're catching
of us more so than if you're playing
fortnight I'm Mac and I just say it
requires very high levels of hand-eye
coordination I accept that you I
pressure you've got to repeat that and
you've got to get good at it and you've
got a practices there are similarities
between that and athletes doesn't make
you enough ly because the level of
athleticism you're sitting on the
[__] couch dog there puddings do you
know means they couldn't catch a bus
these guys they're not athletes you're
not athletes right you might be king in
your own domain and I really respect
that yes but you're not Syrena [__]
Williams yeah you're not doing Cristiano
Ronaldo you're not elite level box a
Tyson Fury all of that [__] you're not
these kind of people right you sit on a
couch and play a [__] game and you do
it fantastically well yeah and you
repeat it and do it over and over again
you're not fit though are you and can I
just say I know it comes across as I'm
hating right yeah I actually think
[__] good on you you're literally
making milli
doing what I love to do game you can
have a want whatever you want not enough
now Brian someone else suggested this if
you're interested in food in the blue
van man area this guy is compelling oh
people have suggested asking yeah ever
sooner before you know imaginary things
folks I didn't think I was imagining it
I mean I wasn't sitting they go this is
out of my comprehension this is
something I couldn't have thought of I
wonder how tall he is cause he seems
quite wide yeah you know me you get that
in America though I feel like if you
lived in America you gained like four
inches that way yeah you see me do the
spicy run in the world before I did the
two times
spicy and the four time spicy as well do
you think this guy calls himself an
athlete you know physically it probably
requires a lot to take on the spicy
noodle challenge why are you being
respectful of this guy but dissing on
our brothers from gaming I'm just saying
like physically
oh he times it hahaha
what are you doing right this is why
it's impressive no wonder he needs that
cold water can I just say I hate the
sound of teeth against metal Fork we're
bringing back one of your favorites and
ours this blue varmint and apparently
mrs. BVM makes an appearance she does
yeah this is a good pollutant it's a
classic blue van man a lot of people
sent me this one he makes it guinness
punch it's sort of weird how much I like
these people without knowing them person
I want to go I really like a friend of
the family oh yeah I want to go to a
barbecue with these people and just sit
there and go get me another hamburger
would you and he goes oh yeah all right
loss yeah yeah yeah coming up buddy I
reckon he would do belt uh barbecue for
oh yeah and he'd also open it and he go
let's tuck in and you'd be like
absolutely can I just say one of the
sweetest things is he's knocked out at
the side here you can scroll back in the
comments so the comments are motoring in
like you'd never have thought on a funny
livestream like this right and that just
questions he can't keep up with how fast
this one so he's Miz's questions he
starts to read me oh so have you ever
thought and that's it I won't see June I
want to say June
the one you see dude but he won't like
one day you never know there's James
nearly honey I love how pure they are
they're so pure they just having a
lovely life like a happy is gorgeous you
know there's this is punching beyond
belief this guy honestly as a couple or
not and can I just say there's nothing
wrong with punching oh no every
self-respecting man should yeah you
should always feel a little bit like I'm
with someone more beautiful so look
that's the way we feel I just want to
say congratulations Dave let's keep it
respectful in the comments of God's
sakes she's a married woman don't start
with negative or dirty disgusting stuff
but either yeah that sort of that that
goes very very quickly Brian because
thank you
gather äj-- milk five-pound ease gathers
virtue the milks about forty to fifty Oh
milk thirty to fifty
yeah juice almost fifty one she's nearly
51 yeah she looks great
well done G like I mean she looks great
regardless but like Fair Play if you
look that much younger than you I she
has had such a great life with Dave a
life of laughter I think yeah a life of
love laughs and living mmm they're like
a proper little motivational Instagram
post yeah what I'd love to do is make
these to walk down the beach hand in
hand and take a photo of them
silhouetted in the Sun you know the time
of my life never failed before yes I do
you know where I look at him he's the
ultimate floor yeah 20 years I want to
be like him yeah I mean yeah if you've
got more BVM stuff we'd love to see it
we're also putting out a compilation of
some of Dave's best bits on the true
Johnny YouTube channel on TG 2 the link
for that is in the description below
subscribe the second channel we've done
some other stuff over there we did a
response to some of your criticism about
the Bilzerian podcast I put out fighting
stuff on there yeah you know if it
doesn't quite fit the main channel it
goes on there and to most of my TG to
stuff little shits on most
other people's main stuff so that's why
you should subscribe fantastic
don't forget to go to our sponsors this
week and we'll see you next week see ya
bye thank you very much responses this
week a new one as well someone we could
possibly both do with stitch fix what do
they do learn well Brian if you could
describe your style in one word a you
casual sophisticated playful Viking
trucked in the wrong century right
instead in warm web but fair play we can
- a tit stitch fix have basically an
expert team of personal stylists
basically you go to their website and
this is the code stitch fix calm forward
slash true these people will style you
okay so we put the link in the
description for everyone who wants that
absolutely and it's although it's a
personal styling service basically
online you go there you give them a bid
of your preferences and after a while
these guys go oh this would be good for
you yeah we're gonna ship that out you
know why that might help me because I
don't have to spend there just browsing
websites exactly where cuz I'm a busy
man you know me I don't wanna have to
sit there and be like oh would this fit
me with that fit but put size and put
the styling but yeah Bob's your uncle
now here's the thing Brian
there is no there's no commitment
required don't like that that's good you
only pay for what you keep so it's just
there's just shipping there's exchanges
and returns it's very easy I've seen
other people doing this or they don't
like it you send it back that's fine I
do what you do like no commitment and if
I don't like it I get a send it back
exact perfect
it's basically your perfect service
thank you so what you got to do is get
started today on stitch fix comm slash
true and get an extra 25% off when you
keep everything in the box that comes to
you stitch fix comm forward slash true
you're probably over done them I have I
the URL yeah how will you be person
that's on the description on the right
oh yeah just like it it's down there
somewhere